[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana les proponemos un
programa la verdad necesario y muy
proactivo en medio de esta guerra de
ucrania de la crisis energética hoy
vamos a ponernos en positivo y les vamos
a proponer soluciones para luchar contra
el cambio climático para ello me
acompañan en este estudio tres invitados
les presento a mariana castaño
periodista especializada en cambio
climático fundadora de ten billion
solution asesoramiento en comunicación
sostenible bienvenida mariana muchísimas
gracias a carlos por invitarme nos
acompaña también adrián tamarite
economista especialista en
sostenibilidad y responsabilidad social
bienvenido mi compañera paloma varón de
la redacción brasileña de recibió y
venida muchas gracias
soluciones al cambio climático hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
[Música]
esta semana en la cumbre de las américas
celebrada en los ángeles el el lema de
cabecera era desafío compartido
soluciones compartidas y de esas
soluciones queremos hablar hoy porque
cuando hablamos de cambio climático es
posible que de repente una nube de
pesimismo se instale en nuestras cabezas
ya que todas las noticias relacionadas
bueno pues no son muy agradables es un
hecho científicamente probado que se
están produciendo alteraciones algunas
irreversibles sin embargo en las
personas expertas en la materia no
niegan que existan soluciones para
frenarlo recuerden que de este tema
depende dependemos todos las
predicciones sobre salud los conflictos
territoriales la escasez de agua la
seguridad alimentaria repasemos algunas
portadas cubera internacional una
estación en el infierno el verano boreal
se presenta con temperaturas
elevadísimas en muchos puntos del
hemisferio norte hablando de soluciones
lakua el bosque entra en la ciudad cada
vez más ciudades optan por nuevos
bosques urbanos para luchar contra las
olas de calor y la revista geo que
también ha decidido hacer el ejercicio
que hoy hacemos nosotros en primera
plana y dedica uno de sus especiales a
soluciones para un planeta mejor con
soluciones creíbles y factibles bueno
como les decía hay un pesimismo
instalado en nuestras cabezas mariana
con qué estado de ánimo como ciudadanos
con qué espíritu debemos abordar este
asunto bueno carlos yo no quiero ser
prescriptiva porque creo que cada
persona cada hombre cada mujer y cada
niño y niña y lo estamos viendo cada vez
más los jóvenes son los que están
tomando la iniciativa en esto de tomar
conciencia cada uno tiene que sacar sus
propias conclusiones pero para sacar
conclusión hay que informarse yo creo en
él informarse hablar actuar hay que
sacar sus propias conclusiones la
información es muy abundante el ipcc el
panel intergubernamental de expertos
sobre el cambio climático acaba de sacar
uno de sus estudios precisamente
focalizados en las soluciones son
documentos que tienen varios miles de
páginas pero hay síntesis y bastante
accesible al público general y
afortunadamente los medios de
comunicación cada vez tratan más y lo
hacéis vosotros aquí carlos en este
programa esta cuestión así que lo
primero sería informarse después hablar
porque cuando se verbalizan las
preocupaciones
no toma más conciencia todavía de que se
puede hacer algo si uno se queda en su
rinconcito preocupándose podemos caer en
una eco ansiedad que nos va a bloquear y
nos va a impedir actuar y después de
esas conversaciones ya hay más
posibilidades de que cada uno pueda
actuar desde pequeño exacto yo esta
mañana pues en vez de tomar el taxi que
generosamente me ofrecisteis tomé el
transporte público porque en europa
tenemos la suerte de tener un transporte
público de muy buena calidad está hoy
voy a comer como cada día comida que no
tiene carne es otro acto por ejemplo que
contribuye a que mi huella personal de
carbono sea reducida pero claro cada uno
tiene responsabilidad a su nivel
informar hablar actuar hoy en primera
plana nos vamos a situar hemos hecho
muchos programas de informe e
información incluso de charla hoy nos
vamos a centrar sobre todo en la tercera
fase en el actuar pero bueno nos
manejamos entonces el espíritu crítico
adrian la información pero necesitamos
ser proactivos no nos queda otra si por
supuesto creo que parte de la ciudadanía
justamente es agarrar y no solo es decir
hay que hacer esto o hay que hacer lo
otro sino realmente llegar a la
actuación y yo diría también inclusive
la ciudadanía corporativa
hay que entender también que no
solamente se trata que las que las
sociedades son los individuos sino
también las empresas las empresas están
conformadas por individuos y son estas
empresas también las que lideran ciertos
cambios y son las que llevan ciertas
tendencias en los países y también en
nivel mundial entonces en ese sentido
hay que justamente agarrar y llevar a la
acción está claro que hay soluciones
también destinado perdona que te
interrumpa empresas y estados pero como
como individuos sería un error no
implicarnos como ciudadanos evocando
responsabilidades mayores que eso es
algo que una cosa que podemos tener ahí
sí sí claro yo diría que bueno para qué
voy a tal cuando hay con tan súper
contaminadores y 1.010 otra vez algo que
también yo propiamente he pensado para
que digamos hago el tri para el que hago
el reciclaje si es que viene un
multimillonario esa y viaja esa
transacción entonces lo hemos escuchado
por supuesto por favor y quien lo a
cuántas cosas claro pero también creo de
que sí no es algo nosotros por nuestra
cuenta no vamos a generar esa conciencia
y probablemente una persona lleve a otra
persona a generar el cambio en su
comportamiento y así también digamos
masificar el impacto no lo pilot behring
en este mapa que decía amar ya no
informarse hablar actuar y luego volver
a hablar son vasos comunicantes como
decía adrián volver a hablar con
personas de esos actos que me corren
paloma yo estoy de acuerdo yo creo que
hay cosas que podemos hacer en
diferentes escalas el ciudadano puede
hacer en su escala personal pero también
en movilización ciudadana para presionar
los gobiernos para que voten las leyes
como aquí en francés por ejemplo hay una
ley que es una ley pionera de
2017 por ejemplo para la trazabilidad de
los productos de empresas con más de
cinco mil empleados y ahora ahí
en aquí en parís hicieron una hay una
audiencia pública sobre para juzgar la
empresa casino que tiene supermercados
en brasil y en colombia sobre la
trazabilidad de los productos porque se
han visto los indígenas son y otros
activistas ambientales han visto que los
productos vendidos por casino en brasil
en colombia por ejemplo son vienen de la
zona de la extracción ilegal de la
minera ción de cosas de amazona entonces
hay leyes hay que presionar también los
gobiernos para que voten las leyes y
para que ellas sean cumplidas así como
las empresas claro
la nacionalidad que también pues
reivindicativa o de exigencia a los
gobiernos como decía mi compañera paloma
les pregunto más bien a las periodistas
tanto mariana como a paloma los más
grandes crisis que hemos tenido tanto la
comida como la guerra de ucrania como
creen que han influido en nuestro
comportamiento respecto a este asunto
bueno pues ha sido muy importante para
para levantar conciencia por un lado
lakovic por sus orígenes
relacionados con cómo estamos tratando
al mundo natural
un inciso el mundo natural somos todos
no es el parque no es la amazonía el
ambiente es todo lo que nos rodea y lo
necesitamos pero a las especies
naturales les estamos reduciendo el
hábitat y sus enfermedades se están
transmitiendo de manera más fácil a las
personas
eso
para mí ha sido una oportunidad perdida
y es que no se ha incidido lo suficiente
en el origen medioambiental de la crisis
del cob y en algo si se así se ha hecho
ahora estamos hablando de la viruela del
mono que está todavía en un estadio más
reducido pero es otra crisis también
sanitaria que tiene la relación con como
los humanos nos relacionamos con la
naturaleza la otra crisis la crisis de
la invasión rusa en ucrania nos ha hecho
darnos cuenta de nuestra dependencia
energéticas en este caso de rusia del
gas y del petróleo
por una cuestión de soberanía pero una
cuestión también
política de no financiar a un régimen
que está invadiendo aún a un país como
como es ucrania los europeos han
decidido de re energizarse con el ri
power y you para reducir la dependencia
energética del gas y del petróleo y eso
va a tener consecuencias muy positiva
pero hay que informar a la población
para que la población sienta que esto es
beneficioso que va a haber que hacer
pequeño pequeño sacrificio pequeños
ajustes por ejemplo en españa el
gobierno ha obligado a las instituciones
públicas todos los ministerios todo lo
que son oficinas públicas a que los aire
acondicionados no estén por debajo del
blog de 17 grados centígrados bueno pues
esa es una medida
hablaba mariana de pequeños sacrificios
lo que pasa es que yo nos hicimos llega
un punto de nuestras sociedades que esos
pequeños sacrificios que en el pasado
también eran interpretados como pequeños
ahora nos parecen demasiado grandes por
el tren de vida que llevamos no lo sé no
decide finalmente son son zona enormes y
también no solamente es el desafío para
los ciudadanos sino también para para
las empresas yo diría también gobiernos
además bastante cortoplacista es decir
se junta
aunque percibimos como esos sacrificios
con gobiernos que tienen miedo con
gobiernos efectivamente y con gobiernos
que probablemente no estén llevando a
cabo las regulaciones ni el enforcement
digamos que es necesario para ciertas
actividades este en el caso digamos de
latinoamérica yo vengo de perú acabamos
de tener un ecocidio un desastre
ambiental a cargo de la empresa repsol
en las costas de lima y ahí justamente
viene mi punto tiene que pasar muy cerca
de las grandes ciudades tiene que pasar
muy cerca de digamos de la mayoría de la
población para que hay esa conciencia
ambiental y para cayese digamos ese
despertar de que debemos hacer algo que
necesitamos gobiernos más fuertes y más
consolidados en la regulación
necesitamos una ciudadanía que esté más
exigente que cuando el gobierno nos hace
su parte también sea la ciudadanía la
que exija que la empresa se haga cargo y
también necesitamos empresas más
responsables no empresas que digamos no
digan no primero no fue mi culpa para
que luego reconozcan y asuman cuando en
realidad esto se trata de un tema
y la responsabilidad y actuar en el
menor tiempo posible precisamente de coz
y dio creo que trataron la semana pasada
en una cumbre de la que pudo y paloma
estocolmo más 50 que hablas disgusto de
este tema del ecocidio eso yo estuve en
las pre conferencias organizadas por
organizaciones no gubernamentales y
asociaciones ambientales y el tema del
cocido que fue tratado en 1973 en la
primera conferencia que sacaron el
concepto de ecocidio que la distribución
parcial o total de ecosistemas y eso
incluirlo a nosotros los humanos
y ahora la ruta es para la lucha para
criminalizar el ecocidio esto entonces
hay muchas iniciativas mundiales para
criminalizar el ecocidio la distribución
de florestas de biomas de ecosistemas y
una de las cosas que hablamos también y
de estocolmo que se habla se habló es
está en construcción la declaración
universal de los derechos del océano que
es que se basa a cuadro en la
declaración universal de los derechos
del hombre pero sabemos que el océano de
nuestra principal fuente fuente de
oxígeno y hay que preservarlo
cuando hablamos de soluciones para
imaginarnos un mapa de soluciones
mariana en qué grupos o cómo podríamos
clasificar estas soluciones
bueno pues las soluciones están por
sectores pero también por niveles por
niveles porque como decía adrián el
ciudadano no tiene el nivel de
responsabilidad que puede tener una
empresa que puede tener un gobierno no
me voy a centrar en los ciudadanos y voy
a hablar de los sectores por sectores
pues las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero que son las que provocan el
calentamiento global tienen un origen
principal que es la combustión de gas la
combustión de petróleo y luego hay otros
orígenes pues como la explotación de los
suelos y procesos industriales la
deforestación los incendios y también
las ruedas de los coches por ejemplo que
no se habla mucho pero las ruedas de los
coches pues producen unas partículas que
son también contaminantes yo tengo un
gráfico y en este caso presenta la es
una radiografía de las emisiones de un
francés una francesa medio y la primera
fuente de neutrones es el transporte en
el caso europeo en la segunda fuente es
el
edificio es decir la construcción y el
funcionamiento de nuestro edificio y
luego vendría el textil y los bienes de
consumo que son el textil pero también
es el teléfono móvil este libro que yo
me he comprado esto tiene una huella de
carbono en un momento una pausa y ha
vuelto la pausa seguimos hablando de ese
mapa y hablamos de las soluciones porque
me regaña sino hasta ahora
[Música]
france24 el arte en todas sus formas
liberté égalité actual y t
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy álvaro cordero como todas
las semanas abrimos para ustedes las
puertas del pasado en un viaje por la
historia para ayudar a entender el
presente para averiguarlo lo mejor es
penetrar en la historia de ucrania y
definir los lazos que han unido y unen a
los dos países
acompáñenme en historia por france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
seguimos aquí en primera plana de recibí
de france 24 dando de soluciones contra
el cambio climático lo hacemos con mis
compañeros mariana castaño y paloma
varón y adrián tamariz economista
especializado especializado en
sostenibilidad antes de irnos a la pausa
estábamos hablando con mariana de cómo
hacemos el mapa no de soluciones y nos
planteaba las marianas recordemos lo eso
es en el nivel francés
france se puede se puede extrapolar a
los países de ingresos medios ingresos
avanzados la primera fuente de emisiones
son los transportes es sobre todo el
transporte diario pero también si es que
tomamos vuelo muy a menudo sobre todo
vuelos trasatlánticos
eso tiene una huella de carbono muy
importante en la segunda fuente de
emisiones en la vivienda y los edificios
en general para uso comercial para uso
hotelero para hospitales etcétera eso es
el 37 por ciento no se habla mucho se
suele hablar de los sabios de la carne
pero de los de la dieta pero no tanto de
los edificios y de los edificios
construirlos el cemento el acero se
necesita muchísimo calor para producir
esos materiales luego el funcionamiento
en la calefacción de nuestros edificios
por ejemplo los electrodomésticos son
cada vez más eficientes pero cada vez
tenemos más cada vez que utilizamos más
cada vez vemos más vídeos en streaming
etcétera y eso necesita mucha energía
luego otros bienes de consumo como puede
ser un teléfono la ropa que llevo puesta
o este libro que no olvidemos que la
cultura también tiene una huella de
carbono y la alimentación la
alimentación es una fuente de gases de
efecto invernadero muy importante y una
fuerza y una fuente no solo de gases de
efecto invernadero sino de injusticia no
hablaba paloma hace un momento del
origen de algunos productos y lo que
está eso implicando para las poblaciones
locales
los pueblos indígenas y luego los
servicios también que tienen la salud
por ejemplo el 5 por ciento de las
emisiones a nivel mundial pues son los
centros sanitarios y los hospitales y
los necesitamos no podemos vivir sin
ellos bueno una vez que tenemos
expuestas más o menos este mapa
empecemos la movilidad vamos a proponer
algunas soluciones y empezamos tomamos
tomemos el primer grupo el de la
movilidad pues bueno yo diría que hay
que cambiar los hábitos no hay que
digamos pensar más en la movilidad
urbana en la movilidad en común diría
que también este es un desafío incluso
mayor para para los países de américa
latina no implica tanto a ciudadanos
como alcaldías a poderes congregaciones
claro por supuesto diría de todos los
niveles por poner un caso el metro de
lima nosotros estamos no nos estamos
tomando muchos años en agarrar y en
tener una línea de metro subterránea
en la construcción justamente genera
tráfico en hbo dieta embotellamientos
horas perdidas muchos autos no solamente
los los colectivos sino también los
particulares que para ganar tiempo se
toman y se convierten en colectivos
entonces hay que actuar rápido hay que
actuar pronto y hay que actuar sobre
todo de forma integrada para que los
ciudadanos las ciudadanas tengan un
transporte público de calidad y
sostenible vamos a proponer una solución
es paloma en el terreno de la movilidad
con los siguientes como ver si la
movilidad para mí es claro que el
transporte público es una solución y
también por ejemplo el hidrógeno verde
para los buses hay ciudades como lima
como mi ciudad salvador de bahía donde
lo que ahora tenemos un metro pero
pasamos es muy reciente entonces para
los buses hay muchos buses en europa en
estocolmo nyon donde estaba que se
utilice el hidrógeno verde que es
separar la molécula de hidrógeno del
agua y para eso claro tenemos que
preservar el agua tenemos que tener el
agua para el hidrógeno verde que es una
de las soluciones para el transporte
público para que no contamine otra
solución también hay que haber cadenas
alimentarias sostenibles eso como
hablamos de trazabilidad y eso es muy
importante porque es una de las
industrias que más contamina como la
industria textil común ambiente uso del
petróleo y la industria alimentaria
marianas hay veces que el ciudadano es
complicado de explicarle que en vez de
un avión pues que a lo mejor hay
que otro transporte como el tren pero se
le va a acarrear más horas
pero como
ejército pues bueno la verdad es que a
veces es una odisea
es una odisea porque para que un medio
de transporte más sostenible tenga
sentido para el ciudadano y no esté
hablando de una activista o de personas
que estamos altamente concienciados
importadas
exactamente tiene que tener sentido a
nivel de las horas que nos lleva a
viajar y a nivel de lo que nos cuesta
para el bolsillo y desgraciadamente
aunque la alta velocidad está muy
implanta pero la alta velocidad también
tiene sus impactos en los territorios no
hay que olvidarlo pero a nivel de
precios no estamos no estamos reflejando
en los precios del transporte a día de
hoy las externalidades que a mí me hace
mucha gracia esta palabra de
externalidades que la inventaron los
economistas para por ejemplo calcular
los efectos negativos que determinada
actividad pues tiene en el medio
ambiente en la salud entonces esos 9
millones de muertos anuales por
contaminación del aire eso es una
externalidad en fin a mí me parece un
ecocidio muy grave y que habría que
darle mucha mucha importancia entonces
lo que tenemos que hacer para que tomar
un tren en lugar de tomar un avión tenga
sentido es que no puede ser que un yo ir
de parís a londres por ejemplo para una
reunión de trabajo para un fin de semana
de placer me tenga que gastar 250 euros
y es una persona que tome un vuelo de
bajo coste con 20 euros haga la ida y
vuelta a pesar de que ese vuelo de bajo
coste tiene hasta 6 veces más huella de
carbono que el tren y eso que el tren en
francia está bastante descarbonizado
porque la matriz eléctrica en francia es
bastante bastante baja en carbono
entonces tiene que tener sentido a nivel
de tiempo y a nivel de dinero y como
tiene sentido a nivel de dinero con las
políticas públicas yo creo que aquí
adrián sabe mucho sobre eso vamos a
bueno o sea no solamente es a nivel de
políticas públicas sino también un
modelo de negocio y en lo que estaba
estábamos conversando sobre la
reconversión el tema de digamos de pasar
de un modelo de negocio a otro yo creo
que es interesante también pensar en que
hay que cambiarla
digamos el framework de lo que nosotros
pensamos que puede ser digamos este
rentable no las empresas piensan que
puede ser responsable o rentable perdón
y para eso yo creo que no solamente
comienza no solamente pasa por los
directivos sino también por
repensar la educación en términos de la
educación en los negocios no yo creo que
si nosotros no tomamos en cuenta lo que
tú señalabas las externalidades si no
tomamos en cuenta que nosotros una
empresa no solamente responsable por el
profit que genera por los ingresos que
genera y las utilidades que genera sino
también por el impacto
social y ambiental que está generando
que inclusive esta gente está haciendo
lo está ocurriendo en desmedro está
obteniendo rentabilidad en desmedro de
lo social y de lo ambiental pues no
podemos pensar en un mundo sostenible ni
en un modelo de negocio sostenible hemos
hablado del transporte de la movilidad
marian ha evocado más o menos la
construcción vamos con los otros consumo
por ejemplo con la dieta a nivel dieta
una dieta baja en carbono supone
consumir de manera más inteligente hasta
qué punto es eficaz el tema de la dieta
como lo ven qué soluciones podemos
proponer el tema de las dietas yo
particularmente lo veo que sigamos sí sí
creo que el punto de la de la angustia
ambiental que que más me toca porque
digo que yo cambio digamos mi manera de
comer y demás pero en los demás y la
comida que se pierde y la comida que
queda digamos este no vendida y ahí está
la base estratagema que decíamos antes
de decir bueno para ello seguir
consumiendo por un ejemplo que un montón
de carne
me hago esa limpieza de conciencia
diciendo bueno pero es que es peor
cuando lo tiran los otros es peor cuando
tal como reaccionamos ante eso que mi
elasticidad digamos no la necesidad o
sea si yo encuentro yo como consumidor y
como persona que podría tener un valle
limitado
pues una cantidad de dinero limitada y
veo que la alternativa de carne está más
barata que una alternativa vegetal pues
me voy por la de carne definitivamente
porque tengo una necesidad que
satisfacer y tengo un dinero limitado la
justicia social díaz y justamente
justamente hay que adaptar también y hay
que tener conciencia de a quiénes nos
dirigimos y en qué contexto hablamos de
la adaptación con cambio climático lo
más yo creo que no se puede aislar el
asunto de ecología con el asunto social
claro todo está muy interliga dow y por
ejemplo cuando hay desastres naturales
sequías
y otros desastres es la población más
vulnerable siempre como con el corrido
también que también es un todo es ligado
no ese entonces es siempre la población
más vulnerable y sufre las consecuencias
entonces eso no podemos aislar los dos
sujetos los dos asuntos y la otra cosa
es también nuestro sistema hay que ver
las consecuencias de nuestro sistema
capitalista el curso mismo que es el
consumo en exceso porque necesitamos
comprar
no sé cuántas europa todos los meses
todos los que pueden comprar claro y
entonces es el consumismo que hay
también y cada persona puede ver y ver
su propia es un precoz y dejando claro
hablamos de consumo y también de no
consumo me imagino mariana es decir de
dar segundas vidas a los objetos de
arreglar reconvertir revivir todo todo
el universo lo que comienza porque está
muy bien y reducir que debería ser el
primer paso siempre porque hablamos por
ejemplo de vehículo yo tengo me gusta
mucho
es un problema pero bueno por ejemplo se
habla mucho del coche hay personas que
dicen si el coche eléctrico está bien
pero desplaza las emisiones y el lugar
la electricidad que producir en la
columna de la derecha es el coche
eléctrico la columna a la derecha es el
coche de combustión es lo que más se
mide estos son las emisiones y las
emisiones de carbono de un coche de
combustión interna de factor que por
cierto la unión europea o el parlamento
europeo acaba de votar que al horizonte
de 2035 estará prohibida la venta de
vehículos de combustión interna nuevo lo
cual es una muy buena noticia para la
salud de las personas primero y luego
para la salud del medio ambiente en
cambio en la huella de carbono de un
coche eléctrico en francia teniendo en
cuenta incluso la producción o sea la
extracción de todos esos materiales el
níquel el cobalto lesionado es la huella
de carbono más reducida en la mitad va a
emitir un coche eléctrico en su ciclo de
vida menos de la mitad que un coche
térmico pero pero el coche más ecológico
es el coche que no se necesita si
queremos si queremos cambiar todos los
coches que hay en el mundo a día de hoy
por coches eléctricos el planeta no lo
vamos a seguir cargando alternativa a la
movilidad activa el transporte público y
luego reducir hay atrás hay por ejemplo
desplazamientos que a lo mejor no son
necesarios y con la pandemia del cob y
de hemos visto pues que las
teleconferencia o el trabajar desde casa
es también posible adrián no bueno yo
estaba pensando en lo que viene después
no porque si está muy bien la regulación
de europa pero pues sabemos de que en
los años 90 en los años 80 a
latinoamérica ha llegado lo que sobraba
del resto del mundo desarrollado
entonces hay que pensar justamente en
que lo que viene después para esos
residuos de digamos de los vehículos y
de otros bienes y servicios que van a
ser adaptados aquí en europa me quedan
ya son unos segundos sujeto verbo y
predicado educación muy importante no
aprender a hablar actuar aprender
y actuar pues muchísimas gracias a los
tres ha sido un placer está en primera
plana de lo más proactivo posible
proponiendo soluciones para contra el
cambio climático a todos ustedes que
pasen una buena semana de llega hasta la
semana que viene aquí en primera plana
gracias
ah